ну, я маю на увазі, яка іронія, чи ти
мене представив, я голова
Німецької партії зелених, яка зараз захищає НАТО
від президента, і я Сполучені
Штати, я маю на увазі, що він бос Білого
дому, і я повинен сказати тобі, що ти знаєш  мої
американські друзі, які все ще були лише
НАТО, очевидно, я маю на увазі, що
пан очевидний загроза безпеці.  Путін, він
не хоче сильного Європейського Союзу, він
не хоче НАТО, і очевидно, якщо
ви подивитеся, щоб утриматися, що нам все ще потрібен
НАТО рівно стільки, щоб продовжувати
санкції, я не хочу всередині банку, я не
бачу жодних причин для цього  скасувати санкції,
доки Путін не рухається вперед і не
зупиняє своїх солдатів на сході України
від того, що вони роблять проти
єдності України. Я не вірю, що
ви знаєте, що це роз’єднує, немає
окремих, це Росія втручається
в  зерно, яке хоче розбити
ваше зерно, це так очевидно, я маю на увазі, що
потрібно бути сліпим, щоб цього не бачити